Go on.
I thought you'd probably come.
Eat.
Yes?
You're really nice, aren't you?
Eat!
It's so good!
I'm so full.
-Looks like you're done.
-Yes.
Here's your dessert.
I'll eat anything.
Here.
What is that?
This is...
Water.
What?
It's ten liters.
It's the minimum amount
of hydration you need.
You want me to drink ten liters?
Not in your condition.
FRUCTOSE
Mix this in.
Fructose is a pure sweetener
refined from fruits.
It's about four kilos.
It's a lot, but its absorption
is second to none.
Your poison was neutralized
and you recovered.
But your recovery is not complete.
Hey, that's dirty.
Usually, protein and starch is ideal,
but there's no time.
Fourteen kilograms
of sugar water.
A miracle will happen.
Inflicted by deadly poison,
the boy's body was weakened
to its utmost limits.
It was further burdened
by the fights that followed.
The liver, which is the body's storehouse,
also reached the last of its glycogen.
More and more abuse came from his fights,
and his muscle cells
were completely destroyed.
Those cells
swore to get revenge.
Their revenge on future abuse...
In the future,
if the same situation arises...
Amazing.
...they will surely
overcome it on their own.
A non-human body bestowed by God.
With this oath to God,
failure is not a possibility.
The boy's body is now undergoing
unprecedented super recovery.